[Music]
everything in the room is white
including the floors beds clothing
lights and even the food is white the
rooms are completely soundproof and the
lights are designed to remove any kind
of Shadows it's called The White Room
torture and it's a form of psychological
torture using complete sensory
deprivation and it can Lea permanent
psychological damage one political
prisoner who endured white torture for 8
months couldn't even remember the faces
of his par and studies show that when
you remove stimulation the brain freaks
out and it can cause anxiety and
depression and because the brain is
constantly trying to establish patterns
it can also lead to hallucinations in
fact just 15 minutes of sensory
deprivation can lead to anadon which is
the complete inability to feel pleasure
if you're interested in learning more
about how architecture is used for
psychological dominance you can check
out my video right here